Shawn Mendes is apologizing for some old
racially insensitive posts after he was
asked about the tweets by a fan during a
tour Q&A session kind of a hard question
I don't want you to take any offense to
it at all I just kind of wanted to do it
for black twitter black Shawn stands
everywhere out there there's a in the
past there's a lot of kind of ignorant
tweets I guess I could say kind of
hurtful offensive tweets that she used
tweeted before I just wanted to know
like do I have you and I think like
recently it's been deleted I don't know
who was it if it was you for wasn't but
if it was or if it wasn't why has it
never been acknowledged arise there
never been anything about it we just
kind of want to know because it's well
we get a lot of hate for us supporting
you um knowing that this has been like
your path and not to say this is you now
or anything like that it's just really
important for us to know like how you
are
[Music]
a lot of things to be moved on from but
I also think that the things that were
saw like I had friends when I was 14 who
would like to take my phone and they
post things of them yeah and like if
they thought I was funny that I had like
2,000 followers in a forest in the South
at the time I was just like not thinking
about it the I'm only friends no idea I
was gonna have 59 yeah yeah what what
that being said yeah yeah also I have a
black lives matter flag that I might
throw on stage so please catch it then
on Saturday Sean posted an apology to
his Instagram stories admitting that he
quote posted some racially insensitive
comments on social media when I was
younger and I am soaring he added I
apologize wholeheartedly for what was
said and understand how offensive those
posts were there is no place for
comments like that and those words do
not represent Who I am I stand for
complete inclusivity equality and love I
believe that yeah and you know what even
the fan the question you could tell that
there wasn't anger there wasn't but she
did you know she was very careful I by
Jhumpa tell she really loves them too
you know not excusing anything that that
people tweet about or say when you're 13
or when you're 12 or however old you
don't necessarily have your head screwed
on straight and you don't know the
repercussions of your actions and the
internet age you can't you can't be
doing that by credit for any young
people out there watching now like you
got him number one learn about the world
before you go off saying anything but if
you happen to have a misinformed opinion
on something you should keep it to
yourself I think yes absolutely and so I
just really liked him and I liked that
he continued he didn't have to post an
apology but I like that he did it
because he I feel like for him he felt
like he had addressed what happened in
that room but make make that apology
because they were living on social media
and people were aware of them and yeah
hurt people's feelings
so really glad that he did that and
Paula is saying you can move on but you
have to learn from what has happened yes
exactly